- Good morning, Believe Nation!
It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message is
The Customer is King.
Over to you, Gordon Ramsay.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Key to a successful business
is remembering the customer's king.
Because without them, we're nobody.
And so I, from a chef's point of view,
always put myself in a
customer's situation,
where I see it from their eyes.
I don't cook for chefs.
Every time chefs come
into the dining room,
first thing they do is turn
all the plates upside-down
and start photographing the food.
And they're constantly
dissecting the food,
as opposed to enjoying it.
So, I always look at it from
a customer's perspective,
because they're king.
And without them, we're history.
- So, when I first took
over Toronto Dance Salsa
just over a year ago...
Wow, almost two years ago.
How long has it been, Alex?
January.
January last year, and it's August.
So, yeah.
Wow, it's been awhile!
So, I took over Toronto Dance Salsa,
and I sat down with Alex,
I hired Alex away from his full time job
to work at Toronto Dance Salsa.
And I said,
"okay, how are we going
to grow this business?"
Here are 10 ways that we
can grow our business,
I gave him a list of 10
things that he could do.
Because if you try to do all 10 things,
you're going to suck at all of them.
I think we try to do
that as entrepreneurs,
we try to do everything,
and then nothing gets done properly.
And so, we had 10 things on our list,
10 ways to market our
business and to grow it.
He had to pick two.
Now one, I picked for him.
One was being a thought leader,
one was sharing content,
one was sharing his opinions,
being on Snapchat, being
a leader, making videos,
that had to be part of the plan.
If you're going to work under me,
if we're going to create
this relationship,
if I'm going to mentor you,
being a thought leader
has to be a part of it.
That's why Alex is in some of the videos,
you've seen him on Entspresso,
you've seen him on #SevenWays,
you see him a lot.
The second way, you pick!
Pick the thing that
resonates the most with you.
And the one that he picked
was having a remarkable
customer experience.
So that anytime somebody
came into our studio,
or anybody, somebody visited our website,
or wrote in to our team,
or tried to call us,
they would have an amazing
customer experience.
Because if the customer loves the service,
they love the experience,
they're going to come back,
they're going to be more loyal,
and they're going to tell their friends.
And so, we made the decision to invest
our resources, our time,
our energy, our dollars,
on how do we make the experience
better for our customers.
And that extends to everything
that we do in the business.
So, it's not just about the
service that we provide, right?
People come here, and they
want to learn dance classes.
Great, you want to give them
a good experience, right?
So, they're in class,
they're learning the steps,
they're learning the moves, great.
Understanding why they came here.
Trying to tap into the deeper reason,
and then give them a better experience
that hits the core of why they
signed up in the first place.
Most people don't come
trying to learn dance moves,
they're coming because they need a break
from their crappy life.
They hate their job, they're
trying to meet somebody,
they just broke up with somebody,
they're looking for some new friends,
it's a thing to do.
And I want to turn the business
from not just being something
that is a thing to do,
to cross off your bucket list,
but something that has a meaningful,
lasting, long-term impact on
the lives of our customers.
So, you then expanded
out to the entire chain
of a lifetime of a customer.
So, when did they first write in to us?
Or do they call in to us?
How is that first conversation going?
What can be better about the
email that we respond to?
Or how can we pick up the phone faster,
or give them a better
experience on the phone?
Then they come to the class,
and then what happens after class,
and what happens in between the classes?
And so, using the lens, right?
This is how we look at our customers
lookin' at our business,
how do we create a more
remarkable experience?
You can go through every little step,
every little touch point,
every little interaction
that a customer has with us,
and a customer has with you,
you could find a way to make it better.
And think of it not just as
providing a great service,
or providing a great product,
not just giving them what they paid for,
but the experience in dealing
with you has to be amazing.
So an example, one of the things
when we're in a phone call,
people have questions.
And it's a lot of the
standard, same questions.
But it's not just about
answering their questions
and being friendly,
but it's always lookin'
for a way to over-deliver.
If you understand their why,
that they're signing up,
why they're interested,
it's looking for something
else that you can offer
at the end after
answering their questions,
that can be that extra bonus to them
where they leave with
their life and their day
feeling better, because of the
interaction they had with us.
And so, if you look at your experience,
look at every touch point
you have with your customer,
think about how you can not just
provide them with the answers,
not just provide them
with a great solution
that solves their problem.
But the entire experience of
dealing with your customers
is not just a pleasant, positive one,
but is an outstanding one.
That they want to rave
about their friends to,
that they can't wait to come
back and deal with you again,
and they want to spread the
mission, spread the word for you.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what is something that you do
to really wow your
customers above and beyond
just giving them a great
product or service?
I'd love to hear from you,
maybe learn something as well
that I can apply to my businesses.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Also, if you leave a comment
within the first couple hours,
you have a chance to win
one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Neal Kerr.
Neal, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
And making that YouTube
video, and posting it online.
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
Thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you!
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is!
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typing)
- I used to work for Warren Avis,
the guy who started Avis Rent a Car.
And he said to me one day,
"Robert, what's the purpose of business?"
And I said,
"oh, make a profit."
And all these other things, and he said,
"no, the purpose of business
is to create a customer."
He goes,
"Everything else takes care of itself.
"If you can create customers,
and create value for them,
"because the answer to
that question is different
"for every single customer,
"then you're going to
have a great business."
- I like to sit down with founders,
and I like to work on removing
friction from process,
whatever it might be.
And creating products that are intuitive.
And one of the things
that I get from working
in the creative space, and being an actor
is really understanding
feeling, and touch, and art.
And you know, it's an art.
Being able to create an
impulse within a consumer
to do something is an art form.
I could probably give
you 10 or 20 examples
of companies that have
really just taken software
that was archaic software that
was untouchable by consumers,
and actually brought it
down to a consumer level.
That is becoming the process
to building a great
software company these days.
You could look at a company like Zenefits.
Where it's like, there's
always been HR software
that's been out there in
some way, shape, or form.
Or you could look at Robinhood.
And there's always been
ways that you can interface
and do stock exchanges.
But making it something
that the average consumer
can intuitively understand,
and touch, and play with,
and use, and have it be
beneficial in their life,
is about understanding the intuition
and the feeling of the consumer.
- I thought that right now
would be the perfect time
to share a customer
service story with you.
True story.
Couple years ago, I got
a call from a young lady.
And was all excited,
she tells me she's looking for a property,
and then she says the word lease.
Our favorite words as realtors.
(audience laughing)
"I'm looking for a lease."
(sighs) You know, unless it's
an $85,000 a month lease,
I don't know.
But I was in a good mood,
so I took that call.
And I said,
"Sure, I'll help you find a lease."
And it turns out, it was
a $5,000 a month lease.
And I took her around
for six months.
(audience laughing)
The term was only a year.
Anyways, I like to finish what I start.
So, I went through with it,
found her an amazing place,
she couldn't be happier.
In fact, she was so happy,
that she called her father
that night, and she said,
"Dad, I got the greatest place!
"My realtor's amazing!
"He doesn't care about money at all!"
(audience laughing)
And it happened to be that her father
was sitting next to
the CEO of his company.
And he heard the story, and that CEO said,
"Actually, I'm thinkin'
of selling my penthouse.
"Maybe I should use that guy!"
Sure enough, I went in, I met the CEO,
and I got the listing of
his $4,000,000 penthouse.
(audience clapping)
While I was sitting that open house
on that $4,000,000 penthouse,
cause that's my favorite thing to do,
(audience laughing)
a celebrity walked in.
And that celebrity walked around,
and he checked out that
incredible penthouse.
And he looked at me and he said,
"yeah, this is cool, do
you have anything cooler?"
(audience laughing)
I said,
"Sure."
So I went back to the office,
and I put together the list
of the coolest penthouses you could find.
And I showed that celebrity around,
and that celebrity ended up
buying an $11,000,000 penthouse.
Which broke the record for Santa Monica.
So from that lease, that
$5,000 a month lease,
which led to that
$4,000,000 penthouse sale,
$11,000,000 penthouse sale,
and it is the gift that keeps on giving,
on, and on, and on.
That is why customer service
is so important to everybody's business.